[Music]
the kardashian-jenner family are going
all out for the holidays despite Kim
Kardashian's break from the spotlight
she's still celebrating Christmas with
her kids and Kanye West in a big way
Kim's pal Jonathan Cheban gave a tour of
the couple's over-the-top decorations on
snapchat Friday only Kim and Kanye would
have a tree this big and check out Kim
yeas gorgeous Christmas lights outside
of their Bel Air home I love that
meanwhile Robin China are gearing up for
their first Christmas with baby dream
and like looking even matches my tree
the proud mom shared adorable videos of
Rob's look-alike daughter on Saturday
including a priceless moment with Big
Brother King Cairo and Kylie Jenner Tyga
and King seemed like one big happy
family
can save you Kyleigh posted her equally
impressive tree showing her and
boyfriend Tyga sharing a sweet smooch
and here's the pair twinning and Kylie's
new clothing line here as she rocked a
massive sparkler on that special left
finger
[Music]
you